this conversation
[Music]
do you is your would you say you would
have a more a solid answer when i said
like would you support a policy kicking
trans women out of the women's sports
i wouldn't even say kicking them out
yeah yeah so they're not excluded in
sports completely yeah but um
having them is like it's is unfair yeah
like where as women we're like having to
like lose out
on opportunities and stuff yeah because
like we're allowing
and that women and that happens that
happens elsewhere as well but it's just
like
in this area we can kind of control it
because
it's like it's awesome yeah
it's art yeah yeah i'll take everything
else
it's been hard to get to this phase yeah
it's so hard
like allowing it to be taken away yeah
just like so easily it's just like oh
yeah
it's so like that's what people have i
always say i think women athletes are
the hardest working
because we work for like nothing
we work for such a small pot and i don't
really like
i understand like why the pot is small
it's just like not this but it's just
when you love doing this [ __ ] and
there's just no opportunity it's just
like sad because i if i could i would
totally spend
my life like i would totally spend all
of my 20s and 30s playing sports but but
why would i do that for nothing yeah
literally and the opportunity just isn't
there and it's sad i mean it is but for
people better than me
it's a very selective yeah yeah like
some people have that opportunity it's
just like for the people who
are able to go down that path and have
the opportunity that's great but for the
rest of the people
is they're not going to be able to have
that opportunity it's going to be taken
away because we're allowing
this to happen and it's like i don't i
don't want my family members down the
line to want to my female family members
who want to be able to play
women's sports and they're like you know
what actually all our spots are filled
we have
on a team of 10 let's say we have um
our nine trans women and one biological
woman or just a team full of trans women
just like you know what we can't accept
you anymore because
it's just over over overpowering women
it's just like
we would want to dominate yeah let's do
it mm-hmm
and it would suck
and we almost have to think of like the
next generation yeah
because there's gonna be younger and
younger trans people
and i mean like i i played with boys
like before puberty but
but
like
like we have to think about the next
generation like my sister's coming up i
don't want my sisters to play against
yeah it's like not even about or not
even have the opportunity to play
because
of
just allowing
trans women to play and that would suck
i would oh i would cry if i
played played as a young kid basketball
just loved it and i'm like i'mma play in
college it's gonna be so much fun i'm
gonna work so hard i'm gonna get a
scholarship and it's just like um
actually you can't play because there's
more trans women now that are playing
and we
want them more than you you're yeah yeah
like you're a great player but
physically you don't have what it takes
it's just like
that's something i cannot control and it
would crush me
and like when you know how much sports
has just like changed your life
personally like there's nothing i my
kids will be in sports
i don't care what sport basketball
i could
i could think of days where i just said
life wishes crap if i just went out i
just got in the car went out and went to
a park and just shot hoops to clear my
mind i i couldn't imagine
where or even like not even that because
i can do that on my own but just going
to practice having a crap day but going
to practice and being able to see my
teammates being able to just
do the thing i love and just be coming
out of it and be like okay
all right i can breathe now and not
having that opportunity just to clear my
head i would
i would have been crazy and you make
lifelong friends like some of my best
friends i made through sports
that's true i wouldn't
i wouldn't be where i am in life if i
did not
if i did not have sports i don't think i
would even be in university yeah
yeah
yeah i don't think i would have i would
i wouldn't have come mm-hmm yeah yep and
it's such a good way for people from
like poorer backgrounds to like get out
of bad situations and go to like school
yeah
yeah it's true
like it it's like um a ticket almost
yeah and just
because it's just not essentially it's
just not plain
there's so many more aspects like
playing is just one aspect keeps you out
of trouble it keeps you nuts it keeps
you not pregnant
bless the lord yeah
like teenagers with too much free time
are dangerous yeah
and just
that one aspect of playing but there's
so much more that comes with being a
female a biological woman athlete and
for if they keeps going down the road
and for that option
not to for women not to have that option
or the option the pool to be
shrunken down to even smaller than it
already is it would be
devastating and just take away so many
different opportunities from women
completely
like
we would just resort to just being
baby makers and housewives in the end
like an athlete is not on the board
anymore no yeah i think that makes
that's why i think these conversations
are so important because a lot of times
i think like
if we don't have these conversations
like people are just afraid of like
offending people yeah and like even it
doesn't even have to be like i do it on
camera but like even behind the scenes
like i think these conversations are so
important to have with people
and especially like amongst athletes
because what i've noticed is the people
that are like parading the hardest
for trans women to be allowed into
women's sports they're not athletes like
when i talk to athletes we gen generally
agree because we've generally played
against men yeah and don't want to yeah
no
no if i didn't
[Music]
he made my nose bleed and he didn't
realize
like and it's like they don't do it on
purpose
like he pulls put his elbow up and then
like hit my nose i thought i broke it
he's like oh that was a really good
screen sorry sorry yeah
that's just the difference between
playing with men and women
there was one time this memory just came
to my head there was one time i was
playing softball with my
um
church and i was fast i was quick i was
able to get to the
the um first first base
quickly
um but i ran into a guy and he was solid
and it knocked the wind out of me now if
i would have ran into a female i
probably would have just blew over
because of my speed but since he's a man
i was like
like it hurt and i was like what the
freak and so it's just
yeah it's just it and when i did co like
i've done co-ed tournaments
say something else i was like what is
that i heard coat and i was like what oh
no no
no no no no no
no drugs um when i did when i when i did
co-ed tournaments like there's
volleyball coming i swear sometimes if
i'm passing and the guy's hitting i'm
just like don't don't don't hit my face
i don't even care if it hits the floor
yeah cuz that's a that's a bullet it's
already a bullet when y'all do it but i
can only understand
oh yeah oh i'd be like one volleyball
game if you guys and i got punched
wait what yeah you guys it was it was
like when before you came down you guys
didn't have any players and then i
played
i don't even know how to play volleyball
and i just helped you guys out and then
i went to the show yeah oh was it early
was it early when no one was there okay
and then i got punched in the face i'm
like if a guy did that would probably be
knocked out oh yeah that hurt so much as
well yeah